al principio hubo una confusión durante
la presencia del presidente ucraniano
boludo en la Cumbre del g7 en Japón al
contestar una pregunta de los
periodistas que tenía dos partes y se
daba por entendido o alguno lo
entendieron así de que él decía que
bakmut ya no estaba en control de las
fuerzas ucranianas Esto fue desmentido
rápidamente por su jefe de prensa y por
él mismo en una rueda o en un encuentro
con los periodistas hoy que decía que
las tropas ucranianas seguían teniendo
presencia en esta ciudad por la que los
rusos llevan peleando más de 10 meses y
que está totalmente destruida Como así
lo recordaba también el presidente
zelenski estas declaraciones iban con en
la misma línea del Ministerio de defensa
de la viceministra que hablaba de que
todavía tenían control de algunas
edificaciones civiles y también
industriales pero Especialmente del
comandante de las fuerzas terrestres de
Ucrania el general alexanderski que
hablaba que si bien tenían el control de
una mínima parte de la ciudad sería
importante de Cara a una ofensiva futura
él hablaba y recordaba que las tropas
ucranianas han venido retomando el
control de territorios en el norte y en
el suroeste de la ciudad y hablaba de
que estas posiciones allí serían
importantes de Cara a un cerco táctico
que es lo que estaría planeando Ucrania
en el futuro Según por lo menos lo que
dice el ejército de este